zwischen dem ukrainischen und dem
russischen konsulat zu bauen
jede art von krieg verachte ich und da
möchte ich unbedingt ein zeichen setzen
sich seit jahrzehnten unterstützen wir
das verhalten eines despoten wir machen
im westen uns so abhängig und ich
verstehe wirtschaft hin und her aber der
preis dafür war definitiv zu hoch
wichtig ist dass man hier ein zeichen
der einigkeit zeigt und ich glaube das
kann eventuell vielleicht auch gesehen
werden können
wir zählen den zehnten tag dieses
russischen angriffskrieges voller tod
leid zerstörung und vertreibung tage an
denen die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer der
technischen übermacht der eindringlinge
ungebrochenen widerstand entgegensetzen
verbissenheit mit entschlossenheit
beantworten aber wird das reichen guten
abend und willkommen zu diesem zdf
spezial so sehr das herz auch mit und
für diejenigen schlägt ihre heimat
verteidigen der verstand ahnt schlimmes
dass nun da putin seine ziele vorerst
verfehlt hat ein schmutziger feldzug
droht der die zivilbevölkerung noch mehr
bluten lassen könnte als bisher immerhin
sind neue verhandlungen angekündigt und
im südosten der ukraine gab es zunächst
die aussicht auf eine mehrstündige
waffenruhe aber geholfen hat sie nichts
seit tagen wird ihre stadt beschossen
sie wollen nur noch weg frauen kinder
weniger alte männer der kleinen stadt im
pinal kiew werden heute in die
hauptstadt gebracht von dort aus sollen
sie mit dem zug weiter in richtung
westen
der ehemalige ukrainische präsident ist
vor ort ein appell an die welt
gesprochen im kampfanzug
sie sehen jetzt warum wir die
flugverbotszone brauchen um die
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen wir
brauchen sie dringend wir brauchen sie
jetzt lasst es nicht zu dass putin die
ganze welt zerstört
es sollte eigentlich der tag werden an
dem sich beide kriegsparteien auf
sichere flucht korridore für die
menschen mehrerer städte verständigen
wollten doch sie kamen nicht zustande
russland und die ukraine bezichtigen
sich gegenseitig die verabredete
waffenruhe in mario pohl und wollbacher
zu verletzten
schwere explosionen erschüttern auch in
der vergangenen nacht wieder den norden
der ukraine ein lokaler ukrainischer
sender hat diese bilder aus tief
ausgestrahlt nach etlichen einschlägen
stehen am stadtrand zahlreiche
wohnhäuser in brand niemand ist da der
löschen könnte
ich habe geschlafen und sie haben
angefangen zu schießen mein haus wurde
zweimal getroffen erst einmal und dann
noch einmal und jetzt bringt es nieder
hilflos muss die frau mit ansehen wie
ihr bisheriges leben in flammen aufgeht
putin sei ein faschist ruft sie
verzweifelt warum denn die ganze welt
die nicht aufhalten könne sie haben die
besten unserer nation getötet wofür und
wohin schaut europa
ohnmächtig schaut europa auf bilder wie
diese ein zerstörtes dorf 60 kilometer
von kiew entfernt ein russischer angriff
hat hier am donnerstagabend zahlreiche
häuser in schutt und asche gelegt
erzählen die dorfbewohner
ich weiß nicht was für raketen das waren
es ist eine tragödie
hier siehst du wie uns mütterchen
russland hilft unsere angeblichen
freunde
russland bestreitet weiterhin zivile
ziele anzugreifen und lässt über das
verteidigungsministerium heute diese
bilder veröffentlichen russische
kampfhubschrauber feuern mit
präzisionswaffen
der ukrainische generalstab
veröffentlicht dieses video angeblich
der abschuss eines solchen hubschraubers
rajiv nur 30 kilometer von der grenze zu
russland entfernt seit tagen unter
beschuss der russischen artillerie und
luftwaffe
wer die möglichkeit hat wer noch die
kraft hat versucht irgendwie aus der
stadt zu kommen viele aber harren weiter
aus unter der stadt in den schächten der
u-bahnhöfe sucht sich jeder seine ecke
das ganze leben gebündelt auf einer
decke am boden
wir hoffen das beste aber sind auf das
schlimmste gefasst wenigstens haben wir
nahrung und luft
das handy aufladen den kontakt nach
draußen nicht verlieren kostbar in
dieser zeit
freiwillige bringen was sie auftreiben
können in ihrer zerstörten stadt
medikamente für die soldaten
lebensmittel für die menschen in den
verstecken niemand verliert seinen mut
wir gehen alle hin und geben unser
bestes um zu kämpfen und wir werden sie
schlagen
die lage sei einigermaßen ruhig in kiew
melden die behörden der hauptstadt an
diesem morgen
zeit abschied zu nehmen abschied von
vladimir meciar netz seine frau oxana
und sein sohn stehen am grab
54 jahre alt wurde war die mir gestorben
auf der straße nur wenige kilometer
entfernt vom friedhof in einem
hinterhalt russischer kämpfer sagt seine
familie
auch ein abschied am bahnhof von kiew
die szenen seit tagen ähneln sie sich
doch jedesmal zerbricht eine welt
alexander hat gerade seine frau und
seine zwei kleinen kinder in den zug
gesetzt das spielzeugauto hat ihm der
achtjährige sohn noch schnell geschenkt
wenige kilometer weiter am stadtrand von
kiew eigentlich während viele von ihnen
jetzt an der universität vorlesungen
besuchen lernen für prüfungen
sie studiere wirtschaft und ich studiere
biologie
19 jahre alt sind maxim und sein freund
sie schließen sich den vielen
freiwilligen an die oft zum ersten mal
in ihrem leben eine waffe in die hand
nehmen und nun gegen die russischen
truppen kämpfen
gelbes klebeband als erkennungszeichen
meine mutter sagte du bleibst hier ich
fange genug saboteure für zwei
mit dem bus geht es an die front und
mit lauten schlachtrufen gegen die angst
ja der entschlossene widerstandsgeist
ära dieser tagen eingekesselt werden
kiew über das ich bereits dunkelheit
gelegt hat eine stunde voraus hier ein
livebild und die bange frage wie wird
wohl die kommende nacht werden in der
von russischen truppen umzingelten
hauptstadt tja die militärische und die
humanitäre lage hängen in kriegen ja oft
eng miteinander zusammen das eine
bedingt das andere
und wie es sich in der gegenwärtigen
situation verhält dazu begrüße ich
bundeswehr general egon ramms zu guten
abend
also eine fünfstündige feuerpause aber
zumindest den mario pohl hat offenbar
kein einziger zivilist die stadt
verlassen können beide seiten werfen
sich gegenseitig vor die waffenruhe
gebrochen zu haben wie interpretieren
sie was da heute passiert ist
also wie sie gerade gesagt haben beide
sollten werfen sich das gegenseitig vor
da wir bisher gesehen haben aus mario
pohl wie zumindest ein eingesammelt oder
gesammelt worden sind um sich für die
evakuierung vorzubereiten
leute ich im augenblick dazu uhr das
belegen zu können dass die angaben der
russischen seite diejenigen sind die
fünf sitzen trotzdem strebt er die
ukrainische regierung weitere humanitäre
korridore an in den nächsten tagen was
glauben sie wird sich russland darauf
einlassen oder es darauf anlegen auch
durch belagerung politische
zugeständnisse zu erzwingen könnte das
teil der russischen strategie sein
es könnte der russische strategie sein
die zivilbevölkerung die aufgabe der
ukrainische staat kräfte zu erzwingen es
gibt noch eine andere möglichkeit die
man bedenken sollte man nachdenken
sollte wladimir putin hat sicherlich ein
großes interesse daran möglichst viel
von der polnischen bevölkerung die die
regierung sogar sehr stark unterstützt
aus dem land heraus zu bekommen um dann
das land einzunehmen komplett
einzunehmen zur entmilitarisierung da
kommt noch ein interessanter nebeneffekt
mit dabei wir haben gehört dass den
bereits über 1,3 millionen flüchtlinge
haben von denen ein ganz großer teil in
polen aufgenommen worden ist man kann
auch durch die steuerung von
flüchtlingsströmen
ich sage dass man vorsichtig die
stabilität in den westlich angrenzenden
ländern also nato-ländern erschüttern
und dann möglicherweise dafür sorgen
dass der zusammenhalt der rat und auch
europas vor allen dingen über diesen
dicht auf diesem wege stabilisiert wird
und das ist auch ein gedanke der geht
etwas anders in eine andere richtung
aber auch dass wir alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten
osterloh interesse daran haben die
zivilisten aus werden sehen ob sich
dieser einschätzung bewahrheitet aber
auch heute rücken die russischen
streitkräfte ja unvermindert auf die
großen städte vor kreisen hier von hartz
iv weiter ein was steht aus ihrer sicht
für die zivilbevölkerung in diesen
städten akut zu befürchten also
offensichtlich wird der kampf um die
städte auch immer mehr zu einem kampf
gegen die zivilbevölkerung bei dem die
zivilbevölkerung immer weiter leidet und
bei der es auch bei der zivilbevölkerung
immer weitere verluste geben das heißt
es wird für die zivilbevölkerung weitaus
schwieriger zu überleben ich sag mal
diesen kämpfen zu entkommen und auf
diese art und weise erleben das ist ein
wichtiger ein wichtiger gesichtspunkt
wird eine möglicherweise auch bei großen
verlust bei der zivilbevölkerung
auswirkungen auf die moral ukrainische
streitkräfte hat und das alles während
der ukraine eigentlich jeden tag größere
waffenlieferungen vor allem aus
nato-staaten bekommt von berlin wünscht
sich kiew jetzt das patriot
flugabwehrsystem können denn solche
waffen den kriegsverlauf wirklich zu
gunsten der ukraine wenden
jim hat jetzt muss ich antworten ja sie
könnten es wenden aber wir sind ja in
der situation wenn wir tatsächlich den
luftraum über der ukraine verteidigen
wollen dann müssten wir auch einen teil
zumindest dieser waffensysteme in der
ukraine stationieren aufgrund der
reichweite die diese raketen haben und
dann sind wir wieder an derselben stelle
wie bei dem thema der flugverbotszone
und das ist eine sache die nato nicht
machen wird und nicht machen kann und
sie dann kriegsteilnehmer wird
nato-generalsekretärs deutenberg wirft
russland vor auch verbotene waffen und
munition einzusetzen also vakuum bomben
und streumunition lässt sich denn deren
einsatz verifizieren und wasser macht
sie so furchtbar
also aufgrund der tatsache dass wir
bilder gesehen haben wo ich sag das mal
relativ eng beieinander springen
einschläge von leichteren oder kleineren
sprengkörpern waren kann man von dem
einsatz der streubomben tatsächlich
ausgehen die streubomben sind in vielen
ländern gerechnet es gibt eine ergänzung
zur genfer konventionen dazu und die
gleiche aussage gilt auch für die vakuum
oder hause kommen das heißt man bewegt
sich mit der nutzung dieser waffen
eindeutig in den bereich der
kriegsverbrechen der leyen und das ist
eigentlich nicht akzeptabel aber ich
glaube nicht dass der russische
präsident mit blick auf den erfolg
darauf rücksicht nehmen müssen die
militärische und ja wenig ermutigende
lage beobachtung von general egon ramms
ich danke ihnen für diese einschätzungen
danke gerne
familien übernachten in metrostationen
unbewaffnete stellen sich panzern in den
weg zehntausende versuchen sich und ihre
liebsten aus den kampfgebieten
herauszubringen beinahe im minutentakt
kommen ja nachrichten aus der ukraine
und zugleich finden überall auf der welt
friedensmärsche und demonstrationen
statt das bedürfnis den ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer solidarität zu zeigen und
dem russischen präsidenten das
stoppschild vor zu halten ist groß auch
in neuruppin in brandenburg kamen
hunderte menschen heute zu einem
friedensmarsch zusammen und zwar unter
der schirmherrschaft des
russischstämmigen schriftsteller
wladimir kaminer ziel der demonstranten
ein hangar auf einem ehemaligen
militärflugplatz heute ein
veranstaltungsort
ich komme aus neuruppin geburtig ich bin
eigentlich mit den russen hier
aufgewachsen wissen ja dass die viele
jahre stationiert waren und den bezug
zur ukraine
leitet sich eigentlich davon ab es ist
egal welches volkes überfallen wird das
ist einfach es geht nicht in der
zivilisierten welt
es sind ja nicht alle finden sich zum
beispiel die generalität oder oder die
die obrigkeit in russland zusammen tun
würde und gegen ihn vorgehen würde dann
würde etwas ändern er alleine denke ich
mal da da wird nichts passieren wir
haben es in der ddr gezeigt mit der
friedlichen revolution dass wir auch
selbst dafür gesorgt haben dass es endet
und ich denke die russin ist ein
riesengroßes volk die können zuerst
recht die beiden ja so unterdrückt und
verboten und unter
druck gesetzt also wenn die auf die
straße gehen alle achtung das ist
natürlich eine nummer dann
für uns ist es einfach hier
ich habe aber eine schwiegertochter
tatsächlich die russin ist und das ist
eine ganz liebe frau und insofern ist es
mir ganz wichtig immer auch klar zu
machen dass dieser krieg nicht russland
ist sondern eben putin und die regierung
die hoffnung die ich würde das land habe
ist dass irgendjemand herrn putin stoppt
und dass die menschen auch entscheiden
können wie sie leben wollen und wie sie
regiert werden wollen und dass es
irgendeine demokratie gibt
und den stimmen der friedens
demonstranten gesellen wir noch eine
namhafte hinzu nämlich die von wladimir
kaminer ich grüße sie nach neuruppin
große andreas die grüße aus
nordbrandenburg unter ihrer
schirmherrschaft stand ja heute der
friedensmarsch von neuruppin was ist
ihre zentrale botschaft an putin aber
auch an die ukraine
ich glaube für eine botschaft an putin
ist ein bisschen zu spät aber ich habe
eine botschaft an russische generalität
diese offiziere haben ein eid geleistet
auf grundgesetz der russischen
föderation
putin als oberbefehlshaber hat gegen das
grundgesetz verstoßen mit diesem
aggressiven krieg in der ukraine
das ist eine historische chance für die
russischen offiziere ihren
oberbefehlshaber zurück machten und
diese nun rechts kriegs sofort zu
beenden
das ist ein appell an die russische chor
in der kabine was ist ihr appell an die
deutsche politik die haben sie ja scharf
kritisierte wegen ihrer zögerlichen
haltung nun sind sanktionen in kraft
waffen auf dem weg in die ukraine sind
in europas möglichkeiten damit erschöpft
oder erwarten sie mehr wir dürfen nicht
denken dass unsere möglichkeiten der
show sind ich glaube die deutsche
führung muss jeden tag dem kreml
klarmachen dass diese krieg eine große
niederlage einer katastrophe für
russland ist
im westen wächst allerdings die sorge
die angst vor putin und auch vor seiner
unberechenbarkeit viele trauen im jahr
inzwischen fast alles zu bis hin zum
einsatz von atomwaffen ist die sorge
berechtigt aus ihrer sicht
putin ist ein ausgebildete
geheimdienstoffizieren diese menschen
haben immer damit angegeben dass sie ein
heißes herz und kühlem kopf haben ich
glaube sein kopfes kühl genug um zu
verstehen dass er sich selbst seine
heimat seine familie er seine liebsten
und seine enkel gehen da jetzt nicht in
den dortigen in einem atomaren vorher
für heizung bilden wir setzen unser
gespräch gleiche wort über diesen krieg
der wie jeder neuzeitliche wohl nicht
allein über die qualität oder quantität
des militärischen entschieden wird im
krieg der waffen spielt nämlich auch
bilder und worte eine entscheidende
rolle die wenigen noch unabhängigen
russischen medien wurden abgeschaltet
soziale netzwerke sind blockiert
ausländischen korrespondenten wird
berichterstattung inzwischen unmöglich
gemacht
krieg
invasion
angriff es sind verbotene wörter für
journalisten in russland dieser tage
zumindest wenn sie damit den russischen
überfall auf die ukraine beschreiben
dann drohen ihnen hohe geld- oder
haftstrafen von bis zu 15 jahren
so hatte es am freitag die duma
russlands parlament per gesetz
beschlossen damit ist eine neue
eskalationsstufe erreicht im russischen
vorgehen gegen missliebige
berichterstattung auch soziale medien
sind ins visier genommen
diese us-firmen wie instagram und andere
werden ganz klar als waffe genutzt sie
erzeugen feindschaft lügen dem müssen
wir uns wieder setzen unsere
streitkräfte schützen
präsident putin die man als geistigen
urheber ansehen darf muss das gesetz
noch unterschreiben doch das gilt als
reine formalie
ich denke was wir hier sehen ist
letztendlich das sowohl russland als
auch china schon lange versuchen die
fällige digitale kontrolle über ihren
informations rahmen zu bekommen
offensichtlich schaltet putin diese
leute alle ab weil er angst hat er würde
das ja nicht machen wenn es alles
bestens für ihn lief denn so ist es ja
nicht das ganze spricht also schon auch
für seine momentane verfassung
schon anfang dieser woche kam es zu
diesen szenen abschied vor laufender
kamera bei tv durch unabhängige internet
sender wird verboten muss die betrieb
einstellen und meldet noch bis zum
sendeschluss dass auch der radiosender
echo moskaus nun verboten ist
es sind solche ereignisse und bilder die
man im kreml schon lange bekämpft
massendemonstrationen in ganz russland
im januar 2021 die menschen rufen nach
freiheit für sich und den inhaftierten
regimekritiker alexei navalny putins
antwort verhaftungen und druck auf die
die überall das unabhängig berichten
die leute fordern die freilassung von
alexei navalny sie fordern dass er
medizinische hilfe bekommt und von
ärzten besucht werden darf
das gleiche schema auch bei dem jüngsten
anti kriegs protesten wie hier
vergangenes wochenende in sankt
petersburg wenn schon bilder davon in
russische wohnzimmer gelangen dann will
der kreml deren auswahl und einordnung
bestimmen über die behinderung der
arbeit hinaus hat moskau mit dem neuen
mediengesetz nun eine weitere bedrohung
gesetzt eine freie und unabhängige
berichterstattung aus russland scheint
damit unmöglich geworden
herr kaminer ihre schwiegermutter lebt
in russland sie selbst haben verwandte
und freunde die nun größtenteils von
russischen staatsmedien über den krieg
der so nicht genannt werden darf
informiert werden wie groß ist denn
deren unterstützung noch für putin
also gezeigt haben die menschen in
russland versucht so zu tun als würde
die politik sie gar nicht interessieren
und sie haben natürlich durch propaganda
auch eine veränderte sicht auf das was
in der welt geschieht sie wissen nicht
was in der ukraine los ist aber sie
wissen genau was in russ und los ist sie
können ja noch immer aus dem fenster
schauen und sie wissen was da jetzt
passiert
menschen hunderttausende fury verlieren
ihre ersparnisse alles ist weg der abend
keine jobs keine arbeit mehr
sie haben keine reisefreiheit sie ist
futsch sie kann das land nicht verlassen
es ist jetzt schon schlimmer als in der
sowjetunion und nicht zuletzt deshalb
hatte der kreml kritiker warnen die
seine landsleute aufgerufen auch morgen
gegen putin auf die straßen zu gehen
haben sie denn die hoffnung dass es über
kurz oder lang doch einen wandel einen
regimewechsel in moskau geben könnte die
russische gesellschaft wacht langsam auf
aus dieser energie und ich hoffe
natürlich sehr dass morgen viele
landsleute von mir trotz allem auf die
straße gehen und gegen diesen krieg
protestieren das ist die hoffnung des
russischstämmigen des schriftstellers
mit deutschem pass wladimir kaminer ich
danke ihnen herzlich für das gespräch
danke nach neuruppin
ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet
ja mit informationen ist das ja so eine
sache wenn sie verdreht ja frei erfunden
sind können sie menschen manipulieren
und dazu bringen dinge gut zu heißen die
schlecht sind und umgekehrt wenn
informationen der wahrheit entsprechen
können sie lebens ja überlebenswichtig
sein hunderttausende ukrainische
flüchtlinge machen gerade diese
erfahrung aus ihrem bis vor kurzem noch
normalen leben herausgerissen sind sie
plötzlich auf der flucht und auf
zuverlässige nachrichten besonders
angewiesen in polen hat herr hebestreit
ukraine getroffen die darin ihre neue
aufgabe sehen
auf ukw 98,6 das radio rmf ukraine seit
mittwoch online herr vor allem junge
journalistinnen und journalisten aus der
ukraine sitzen hier im polnischen krakau
am mikrofon und informieren ihre
landsleute auf beiden seiten der grenze
was sie bei der einreise und in polen
erwartet das hilft den geflüchteten und
auch ein bisschen denen die am mikrofon
sitzen
wenn ich hier bin ist das gut für mich
ich habe da nicht so viel zeit mich mit
den ganzen schlimmen nachrichten aus der
ukraine zu beschäftigen ich bin nicht so
gestresst das hilft mir also sogar
rmf ukraine gehört zu polens erster
privatsender der seit 1992 kurz nach der
wende gegründet wurde inzwischen hat er
vier programme jetzt unterstützen sie
die geflüchteten mit ihrer arbeit
nicht durch wirtschaftliche hilfe kommt
von herzen denn jeder polnischen stadt
von der grenze bis es um mehr gehen die
menschen auf die bahnsteige und teilen
alles was sie haben ich bin selbst
völlig überrascht dass diese hilfe schon
über so viele tage anhält und dass sie
überhaupt so schnell in der lage waren
uns zu mobilisieren katholischer bin ich
meinen besten tag stadt geschossen und
hat so wie ihm geht es vielen in polen
die hilfsbereitschaft für mittlerweile
fast 800.000 ins land geflüchtete macht
sie stolz und ist für die die über nacht
alles zurücklassen mussten
überlebenswichtig manche finden direkt
anschluss bei verwandten doch die
meisten sind hier gestrandet in
flüchtlingsunterkünften oder hotels
wir wohnen nicht weit weg von der grenze
in der region liv und sind deswegen hier
hingefahren weil es nicht weit weg ist
wir sind hier in sicherheit ich hoffe
aber dass wir in zwei wochen zurück nach
hause können
viele realisieren inzwischen dass diese
hoffnungen nicht in erfüllung gehen
könnte sie nicht so bald in ihr altes
leben zurückkehren werden
ich kann das gefühl gar nicht
beschreiben wie es mit ich war managerin
in einer internationalen firma ich hatte
wirklich alles was ich brauche für mich
um mein kind privatschule auto tolle
wohnung in kiew und gutes einkommen
jetzt habe ich gar nichts hier und ich
weiß gar nicht was ich tun soll
[Musik]
polens regierung stellt sich darauf ein
lange für die geflüchteten sorgen zu
müssen
2500 von ihnen sollen jetzt den
nagelneuen sozialwohnungen untergebracht
werden auch ganz schnell haben die
polnischen behörden den weg frei gemacht
für das ukrainische radioprogramm
wir helfen so wie wir es am besten
können wir können radio machen also
machen wir radio das hilft dahinter
steckt nichts kommerziell ist wir senden
keine werbung wir machen das nicht um
geld zu verdienen wir arbeiten mit
menschen die gekommen sind um zu helfen
bislang sind es 10 die am info programm
für die flüchtenden arbeiten aber
ständig melden sich neue interessenten
anastasia kommt aus dem südwesten der
ukraine
ich bin hierher gekommen weil ich mich
irgendwie schuldig fühle menschen
kämpfen mit der situation in der ukraine
und da kannst du nicht einfach nichts
tun ich möchte etwas machen zumindest
das was ich machen kann
dazu gehört aus krakaus alter festung
ihren landsleuten zu melden die polen
sind für ihre nachbarn da
ja schon vor dem ukraine krieg war jacko
für ein wichtiger verkehrsknotenpunkt
nur 90 kilometer von der grenze entfernt
auch nach lemberg ist es nicht weit aber
nun entwickelt sich die stadt immer mehr
zum fluch ziel für tausende ukraine in
der hebestreit ist vor ort hannah wie
bewältigt die stadt eigentlich diesen
jahr unglaublichen ausnahmezustand
das glauben eindeutige statement
beantworten sehr gut denn die
flüchtlinge sind nicht unbedingt hier in
diese gegend gekommen dieser ort ist
mehr ein eine art drehscheibe für die
versorgung all derjenigen die
irgendetwas in die ukraine transportiert
seines hilfsmittel oder seines andere
dinge auf dem flugfeld sehen wird
täglich riesige militärmaschinen da wird
allerlei zeugs ausgeladen da möchte man
gar nicht so genau wissen was das ist
und wie das möglicherweise über die
grenze kommt hier selbst sind wenige
geflüchtete untergebracht die regierung
sorgt dafür dass das meer im grenznahen
bereich irgendwie stattfindet viele die
verwandte oder freunde in der ferne
haben sagen wir wollen über nach
warschau oder auch nach berlin da werden
ja auch einige erwartet sehr viele
erwartet und die regierung sagt er jetzt
auch schon sie zu dass sie lieber die
kleineren städte geht das ist einfacher
wohnungen zu kriegen es kann also sein
dass sich die lage hier noch verändert
auf jeden fall ist es so dass die
us-amerikaner des militärs hier
stationiert ist unterkünfte hatte wollte
mir gedacht hatte warum das eigene
bürger unterbringen diese unterkünfte
sind leer das kann man gegebenenfalls
auch noch wieder aufmachen und die
zahlen sind ja wirklich immens fast
800.000 flüchtlinge sind inzwischen in
polen angelandet allein gestern kamen
über 100.000 geht denn die regierung in
warschau davon aus dass alleine stemmen
zu können oder erwartet man jetzt auch
von den europäischen nachbarn dass die
kontingente übernehmen
also da hört man so konkret nichts ist
so dass wir sehr stolz auf das dass man
hier leistet die regierung hat einen
großen rahmen geschaffen den die
bevölkerung mit leben erfüllt also was
wir erleben auf den bahnhöfen an den
grenzen gegangen überall kommen die
leute versuchen zu helfen nehmen
gestrandete und neben flüchtlinge mit
und versuchen die irgendwo
unterzubringen also die
hilfsbereitschaft ist sehr groß und der
polnische aussenminister hat heute auch
noch mal gesagt alle die da noch kommen
sind willkommen ganz gleich welcher
nation und welcher welcher religion das
ist für polen auch ein großes statement
und auch der amerikanische außenminister
blinken konnte sich heute davon
überzeugen von dieser großen
hilfsbereitschaft hat sich ein
persönliches bild von der lage im
grenzgebiet gemachte welche botschaft
hatte blinken hinterlassen
ja das war ein wesentlich sogar
seelenmassage für die pole und ein
dankeschön für das was hier seit vielen
wochen geleistet wird ansonsten hat er
das wiederholt was us-präsident beiden
schon gesagt hat er hat bestätigt dass
kein zentimeter nato territorium
aufgegeben wird und auch nochmal an die
10.000 us soldaten erinnert die in polen
und auch hier in der gegend stationiert
sind also geld drucken und vor allem
moralische unterstützung aus dem mund
und den händen des amerikanischen
außenministers blinken einer danke für
diese beobachtungen live im südosten
polens
ja wie viele ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
werden wohl noch vor putins bomben
fliehen insgesamt zehn millionen
menschen hält der migrationsforscher
gerald knaus für möglich schon jetzt
hätten mehr flüchtlinge die europäische
union erreicht als im gesamten
bosnienkrieg eine geschwindigkeit die
zeigen würde dass wir vor der größten
flüchtlingskatastrophe des zweiten
weltkriegs stehen so gerald knaus ja es
ist eine katastrophe keine frage und
doch steht ja eine unglaubliche
solidarität gegenüber mehr als die
hälfte der bundesbürger das zeigen
umfragen wollen spenden ein viertel kann
sich vorstellen menschen aus der ukraine
bei sich zu hause aufzunehmen eine
bereitschaft die längst auch teile der
berliner hotel branche erfasst hat
ausgelöst durch die tatkraft eines
einzelnen
sonst checken hier touristen ein jetzt
geflohene aus der ukraine
die lobby dieses apartment hotels in
berlin kreuzberg eine anlaufstelle für
die die nach tagelanger flucht eine
unterkunft brauchen
florian wichelmann betreibt das
apartment hotel und er will helfen hat
seine unterkünfte kurzerhand kostenlos
zur verfügung gestellt so apart hausrat
und haus funktioniert genau wie ein
hotel das heißt wir sind eigentlich gut
ausgelastet aber niemand ist zu 100
prozent ausgelastet da ist immer noch
was frei und wenn es frei steht dann ist
es de facto auch machbar die leute
unterzubringen
marina und ihre beiden töchter haben
heute eines der apartments bezogen sie
sind aus dem heftig umkämpften charkiw
geflohen hier ein video dass marina vor
ein paar tagen gemacht hat russische
soldaten auf der straße vor ihrem
fenster
jeden tag fallen bomben erzählt sie sie
hat ihre kinder genommen und eine kleine
tasche und ist einfach losgelaufen zum
bahnhof wollte nur weg
sie kann kaum glauben wie viel hilfe sie
bekommen haben an der grenze und jetzt
hier
wir wurden die verwandte aufgenommen mit
offenen armen willkommen geheißen
unsere mama hat alles richtig gemacht
sagt tochter xenia
sie hat uns gerettet
florian wichelmann hat sich mit helfern
vernetzt die die geflohenen von der
grenze nach berlin bringen und eine
internetseite initiiert every bett
herbst jedes bett hilft so wurden schon
150 appartements vermittelt das ist
super wichtig weil wir
haben teilweise daran wird auch nicht
mehr die ressourcen
selber wenn wir die transporte
organisieren dann auch noch persönlich
für jetzt in unserem fall über 250 leute
auch noch die unterkunft selber zu
organisieren und die vorstellung ist
stellt man ernsthaft vor du bist
unterwegs zur grenze mit frauen kind und
die ganze wird dir gesagt männer beim zu
hause und du musst deine familie
verabschieden dann hast du auch nur den
wunsch wenn meine familie unterwegs ist
auftritte kommen wie gut unter
sie sind gut untergekommen wie es für
sie weitergeht wissen sie nicht doch für
die nächsten wochen können marina und
ihre kinder erst mal bleiben und zur
ruhe kommen und
soeben hat uns eine traurige nachricht
aus berlin erreicht marinas schwester
schwager und nichte sind auf der flucht
auf eine mine gefahren und dabei ums
leben gekommen
die not der menschen ist groß und wenn
sie liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
helfen wollen dann spenden sie bitte
weiter auch an das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die iban
nummer lautet de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 alle informationen auch im
internet unter spenden zdf de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
rund 18.000 ukrainische flüchtlinge sind
in deutschland bereits registriert
stündlich werden es mehr für bund länder
und gemeinden gleichermaßen eine
herausforderung die kommunen etwa die
beraten zusätzliche
unterbringungsmöglichkeiten vor die
bundesregierung will allen geflüchteten
aus der ukraine
integrationskurse ermöglichen verletzte
und kranke menschen sollen auf kliniken
im gesamten bundesgebiet verteilt werden
sagt heute gesundheitsminister
lauterbach alles gut und richtig aber
solidarität setzt verstehen ja
verständnis für die lage des anderen
voraus und das sollte nicht erst im
großen konflikten beginnen das beginnt
im kleinen ein ukrainisch russisches
paar in münchen machte es beispielhaft
vor
seit tagen sind sie hier in münchen auf
den beinen packen hilfspakete für die
menschen in der ukraine
wenig schlaf keine zeit zum durchatmen
mittendrin die 42 jährige koordiniert
die lkw transporte an die grenzen auch
sie am rand der erschöpfung dazu noch
die sorge um ihre familie
in alten kinder bei
alle booten sind stehe
habt ihr das gewollt habt ihr das
gewollt
ihre eltern wollen in kiew bleiben um
jeden preis nur ihre schwester mit den
beiden kindern konnte aber überreden zu
kommen ich habe am ersten tag des
krieges um halb sechs und meine
schwester ein anruf genügt und
wir sofort nachbar stunden
symbolisiert sie losgefahren seitdem
leben sie hier auf engstem raum alr ihr
russischer man dimitri ihre kleine
tochter und schwester olga mit den
söhnen boris ackers die flucht sagt olga
habe sie wie im trance erlebt ihr mann
musste zurückbleiben kämpft jetzt gegen
die russen seit ihrem abschied konnte
sie nicht mehr mit ihm sprechen dazu die
sorgen wie es weitergeht
ich weiß nicht was morgen auf mich
zukommt ich weiß nicht was ich anfangen
werde sie haben mir mein ganzes leben
genommen
gemeinsam mit ihren russischen schwager
verfolgt oder die nachrichten die bilder
aus der zerstörten heimat das leid der
menschen es wird immer schlimmer
mitten in wohngebieten
bombardierte weit und breit keine
militär ziele sind ich weiß nicht was
dann der gedanke dabei ist also aber
menschlich ist das nicht
da fällt es schwer über den krieg zu
sprechen die bilder kann sie einfach
nicht ertragen schon früh habe sie eine
eskalation befürchtet doch niemand habe
ihr glaubt die russische familie ihres
mannes hält noch immer an putin fest für
beide unerträglich den kontakt zu ihr
haben sie jetzt abgebrochen
es einfach durch die situation ich kann
das auch nicht so richtig freuen
jeder hier habe eine eigene traurige
geschichte doch was alle verbinde sei
die liebe zu den menschen in ihrer
heimat wir zeigen auch hier das via
ukraine sind und dass wir unsere
unabhängigkeit für unsere unabhängigkeit
hier auch kämpfen werden
und auch morgen wird alles wiederkommen
um zu helfen dass er das einzige was sie
hier in diesen tagen rattle
seit einigen tagen bitten wir ja
menschen die noch in der ukraine
ausharren und aushalten darum und deren
alltag in der katastrophe zu schildern
also wie sie den krieg erleben was sie
erleiden und wie sie damit fertig werden
einige schicken uns handy videos
sprechen mit uns über skype immer mit
dem ziel dem kriegsgeschehen das
abstrakte zu nehmen ja eben die maske
herunterzureißen gedanken gefühle ängste
und sehnsüchte alles hat platz in dieser
rubrik
erst gestern haben wir erfahren dass
russische soldaten nach karten von der
gegend besucht haben wir waren
und wir dachten wie dumm es gibt hier
keine orte die sich für sie wären es ist
nur ein ganz normaler ort wo menschen
leben keine krankenhäuser oder wichtige
objekte nicht
und deshalb dachten wir das sind
falschinformationen um uns angst zu
machen und am abend bin ich raus auf die
straße und zu rauchen
das blitzte es vermeiden wir am
hellichten tag fünfmal
ich hatte
bumm bumm
es war so laut
ich habe solche angst
ich bin schnell zu meiner familie
wir haben uns alle umarmt und geweint
dann haben wir entschieden dass wir an
einen sicheren ort in salzen und
am morgen sind wie zum zug
ich hatte eine schreckliche nacht im zug
ist war komplett voll
die sind jetzt sicher wir sind in lief
in einem appartement aber wenn du in der
ukraine lebst dann fühlst du dich
nirgendwo sich ja ich weiß nicht
vielleicht bleiben wir für eine nacht
und dann gehen wir in die berge
ein sicheren ort in unserem land
guten tag an alle ich bin leitende
krankenschwester des zentrums für
blutwäsche fresenius medical care
ukraine in der stadt terni hilft mein
ganzes tolles team ist am arbeiten
ungeachtet dessen dass in unserem land
krieg herrscht alle patienten bekommen
hier eine blutwäsche danke euch für die
unterstützung vielleicht werde ich noch
einmal aber ich kann einfach nicht es
tut mir einfach alles so leid
ich bin in meiner wohnung in kiel ich
kann ihnen nicht zu viel zeigen wenn man
mich dann leicht lokalisieren kann das
könnte für mich gefährlich werden
glauben sie mir in kiew kann alles und
jeder zum ziel werden vor zwei tagen
haben russische sogenannte
präzisionswaffen eine kinderklinik
getroffen anstelle des hauptquartiers
der armee und zwei kinder starben
[Musik]
ich hasse sie wissen sie meine mutter
ist gebürtig aus russland und wir haben
viele verwandte in sankt petersburg die
russen glauben dass wir nazis sind sie
wollen die ukraine entnazifiziert sehe
ich denn etwa aus wie ein nazi
sie töten unsere eltern sie töten
unserer kinder sie töten uns sie
befreien uns nicht sie töten uns
deswegen sehen sie hinter mir ein gewehr
an der wand
ich will dass die welt dass sie in
deutschland wissen dass die ukraine ganz
normal arbeiten wollen wir wollen nicht
durch luftwaffen und ballistische
raketen sterben ich habe viele leichen
gesehen hunderte damals in meiner zeit
als kriegsreporter im don was aber ich
habe nie hunderte brennende panzer
gesehen hunderte militärtransporter
entflammen die russen haben keine taktik
sie kommen nach kiew wie in einen
flaschenhals und die ukrainische armee
kann sie zu hunderten zerstören es ist
kein krieg es ist dahin ich weiß nicht
ist ein genozid
soweit die wütenden mitunter
verzweifelten stimmen aus einem land das
so schnell nicht wieder sein wird was es
einmal gewesen ist was von der
selbstbestimmten der demokratischen und
freien ukraine am ende übrig bleibt das
hängt mehr denn je vom widerstandsgeist
ihrer bewohner ab ein frieden auf dem
verhandlungsweg so wünschenswert er auch
wäre im augenblick könnte er wohl nur
ein diktat frieden von putins gnaden
sein und das entspricht sicher nicht den
zukunfts vor stellungen der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
ja und wie soeben die
nachrichtenagenturen melden soll es am
montag die nächste die dritte runde der
sogenannten friedensgespräche zwischen
der zwischen russland und der ukraine
geben mit welchem ergebnis dann auch
über das war unser zdf spezial danke für
ihr interesse einen guten abend noch und
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
maybrit illner spezial mit dem thema
krieg in der ukraine mit dabei csu-chef
markus söder die deutsche marine rinn
marina weisband und zdf journalisten
claus kleber maybrit illner spezial
sonntag 22 uhr 15 im zdf
[Musik]